aber wer findet so was ich freue mich es
läuft und niemand in seinem leben hier
durch den entlegensten ecken von dieser
jump map und klickt einfach jeden blog
an
oder doch servus skills und herzlich
willkommen zu einem neuen video heute
sind wir wieder auf play meine t und
zwar haben wir ein neues jump mexiko
statt pommes bisschen anders machen und
zwar spielt einfach mal die runde ganz
normal da die leute unter den zügig
vorstellung schreiben sie bringe mal
wieder eine richtige jumping ohne meine
ganze kampe gründe
und ich denke so ey alles klar sind der
komplett vorbei am gedanken und deswegen
bringen heute einfach mal eine richtige
ohne zusätzlich das sieht vorstellung
schreibt unbedingt nach unten in den
kommentaren was ihr davon haltet ich
hab's mir eine weile überlegt beheben
wenn es wieder zieht vorstellung heißt
dann den leuten vorher noch in dieser
runde jump liegt drauf zu drücken obwohl
sie die vielleicht habe sie gar nicht
sehen wollen vielleicht doch obwohl die
meisten hat mich danach gefragt haben
gemeinsam ihr dadurch die ganze runde
hoch deswegen heute so als kleines
experiment klappt am besten einfach in
die kommentare wir es findet sollte ich
wenn ich ein ziel gut vorstellen
die ganze runde spielen und euch zeigen
oder einfach wurde steffen heidrich
zeigen wie es am liebsten hamburg
einfach in die kommentare
ich lese die kommentare und nehmen dann
euer feedback gerne auf die ja das hier
ist ein klassisches module im gegensatz
zu weil ich sehe jetzt erst mal im leben
dass das modul von schwert ist krass und
silin ist mit auf dem teams wie der
titel in den tipp für das siegel gegeben
sind fleißig am ball sagt mir du bist du
blind bist ja aber bitte flex ausmachen
ja ich bin der aufnahme würde ich auch
leugnen ja ja
wir rocken heute übrigens wieder ganz
klassisch die sie bisweilen shader
medium kombination mit dem animated axe
effekt in diesem 6 dieses modul 6 ist
ich weiß nicht wer den plänen team da
ins hirn gilt was wir das als medium
einstufen
es ist so kalt es ist schwerer als
meisten haben bürger ja ich schon eher
eine art moderne design abhoben bisschen
fakt indirekt aber letztens aufgefallen
dass viele böse wörter in meinen
aufnahmen verwendet man videos rein
packe und die gar nicht zensiere fragt
soll ich das lassen wir auch mal die
kommentare schreiben wenn es klappt
jetzt in zukunft statt [ __ ] immer touch
oder frischen grab gerät keine ahnung
was karotte oder so sagen soll dann
schreibt man die kommentare
würde mich interessieren ob er so was
stört ehrlich gesagt weil mir fällt gar
nicht auftreten ich rede
nein nein mann der vorletzte sprung was
ist das denn
das gibt's doch nicht neu in der runde
ist von hier aus nieten und dann zack
ganz klassischer kam es auch geschafft
du musst aber auch double job in wien
wildern diese module 60 so heftig geht
das hier ist klassik also das ist quasi
steinzeit im brawn
das macht es auch relativ meinte der
eine letzte springer den habe ich glaube
ich noch nie geschafft
ja ja trotzdem bis zu einer demo ultras
teilen muss also ich habe schon oft
doppelt samt auch mit gutem timing und
war trotzdem nicht gereicht
jetzt hab ich geschafft volker leiß
alter wir erreichen neue höhen leute
kämpfen hatte zum ersten mal dieses
minuten geschafft hatte ich noch nie
okay es gibt auch echt viele viele neue
module da war das dhb-team schön fleißig
okay dann ja
terry laut sounds sind wahrscheinlich
die physiker mit dem jeep und jetzt in
ihrem deathmatch leute und ich würde
vorschlagen dass wir erstmal einander
finden ärzte direkt und vergibt der mich
noch folgenden anziehen kann ein
bisschen breakaway magath ich wollte mit
der angel kita ist so wichtig dass es so
unfassbar krasser vorteil
ich kann mir erst mal ich kann mir ein
apple kraft aber zum thema apple gleich
mehr leute nochmal erstmal den ein hier
und ja dann citigroup lerne dann suchte
ich gleich mal ja nicht so bild wir
müssen glaube ich hier unten rein leute
also quasi in diesen berg da rein nicht
wahr
in diesem bereich dar ein jetzt gehe ich
mal da lang wo ich glaube das ist bis da
da bist du genau das buch genau da darf
ich jetzt gestern abend schon aktiv ist
nicht gefunden
wo ist das hier bestellt für euch
nochmal nach ihr geht quasi hier unten
in diesen großen eigenen reihen
sie müssen noch mal kurz von außen also
drin schaut beim so sieht das aus wie
ihr papa passt da geht sie runter und
ich wirklich wunderschön mit china was
muss ich sagen so geht er rein wir links
an dem haus vorbei an diesem haus hier
hinten in diesen formaten zu gezimmerten
gang rein und dann ob sie auf diese
lücke dazwischen jeweils ich probier s
mal aus größen wie das also man muss
konnte
wer findet denn sowas leute seht ihr
dass ihr müsst einfach auf das hintere
viertel von diesem casting anklicken
oder sind einfach 1234 gold äpfel alter
schwede
aber wer findet so was ich freue mich es
läuft niemand in seinem leben hier durch
den entlegensten ecken von dieser jump
league map und klickt einfach jeden blog
an
oder doch leute man sieht nichts als ob
mein gott ich wirklich kommen nicht
drauf klar dass irgendjemand das dinge
gefunden hat aber leute wir haben
natürlich die besten informationsquellen
für euch akh ist sie die am start
und ja jetzt habt ihr ein neues wembley
physik wird probieren direkt aus
bisschen was zu machen und das hier ist
echt schon okay also viel gold äpfel mit
dem eintägigen treffen haben wir bei
fünf gipfeln und das ist echt genial
holen
wir können ja weil apple essen wie
andere kram was zwischendurch snacken
ist für die spieler natürlich auch nicht
optimal
okay der kosten zwischen unserer extra
herzen läuft denn nur eins egal alles
klar
so leute wir haben immer noch vier von
fünf gold apple und sie hier zu schlagen
ja dann sollten die eigentlich auf
kämpfen bevor irgendwann sagte team
passen scharf stein schweren ja fix aus
okay ein bisschen warten bis sie ja
genau
laut potthast relax hallo hallo hallo
ok damit wohl glaub ich einen kleinen
teil miteinander in der leitung aber
wahrscheinlich kommt gleich post die
skelette von der server die adidas hat
fliegt so aus minecraft raus aber wo ist
jetzt hier der andere und der hell da
ist er eisern gerne und da ist auch
immer das getan und er hat noch ein
leben und wir haben drei gold apple so
emma von gold schenken wir so ritsch zu
den gold äpfeln hatten wir dass sie gut
gefunden haben warte wilden apple sein
müssen apple bruder
okay er spricht schon mal kein deutsch
spricht nur russisch wie wir gegen
erfurt auf hin soll hinnehmen ja weil
alle wissen so wissmann und co jetzt
denkt er natürlich so krass moneyball
dafür gegeben vollkugel her genau ich
habe ein herz
dabei weiß ich dass wir einfach
insgesamt so viele gipfels selbst hatten
und dass er wahrscheinlich trotzdem kein
land sehen wird trotzdem wichtig straith
und dann haben wir hier wurde mit 15
kids gewonnen sie will ihn hat es leider
nicht geschafft ist auf dem weg raus
geflogen
aber leute sehr sehr wertvolles sieg
wird sehr sehr wertvoll und das ist
wirklich ein geheimtipp das hat nämlich
niemand zufällig gefunden ja das was man
heute haut rein bis zum nächsten mal wie
gesagt mal in die kommentare